[Applause]
yo
yo yo what
happened there are you okay
oh
okay so the one who breaks the egg first
loses so i won
that's an easy win for me thank you good
matchup
let's go back inside
i don't want it
sorry i'm sorry
that hurt felt like my hand come up
[Music]
and the first one the first one i had
like this one and this one
it bounced from this one and then here
this one
[Laughter]
you ready for this i've never been more
ready in my whole life i thought
okay no no i wasn't ready
nice one nice
mic check yeah
me
[Applause]
[Music]
i trusted you this is your side
[Laughter]
it's gonna work it's going to work
i got here oh
i almost dropped it
did
i have been acting all these years but
this is my normal voice
hello and guys we heard there's still a
lot of you
who haven't subscribed don't don't do
that remember to subscribe
oh i loved my so help pongfinity and
subscribe to our channel
hey i'm wrong way around
it's 4 00 am not tired
we still have one hour of cleaning
do some cleaning
he's watching me like a hawk
i could do that like when i was four
years old
oh lovely
[Music]
always
i have each other you can stay under my
umbrella you can stay under my umbrella
under my umbrella
let's start with the basics
almost
i just need one more
[Applause]
oh
straight down on your side
nor mine
[Music]
no three three come on emil you can beat
him
thanks for the support if emil wins this
sorry easy but no
no no
okay i got it
just missed it a tiny bit and guys if
you want to get one of these
skip the weights skip the dumbbells all
you need is a pongfinity
stretchatron 5000. five reps a day
is all you need and it's so easy to use
you can show up to the gym looking cool
looking trendy but
that didn't happen this is windy ping
pong
it actually
okay and we are ready
how can we like keep the game going
like this
[Applause]
it actually worked i don't want to show
my finger nails
i love those fingernails yeah thank you
my favorite color
backspin
i i didn't know what i was filming
[Applause]
oh
i actually done nothing there i really
wanted to hit
okay i'll set the score for mika to try
and beat
[Applause]
that's two here we have the real sensei
and sensei palawan
may the best backhand win
straight
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you can buy these from pongfinity.store
and during the first 24 hours we've got
a special campaign
where every single order gets a greeting
card
so for obvious reasons it's not allowed
to move the table
too good
[Laughter]
why are you oh i was a bit left left
outside of the rally
cuckoo
[Applause]
leave your ideas for the next
so today we're going to show you
different ways how to play table tennis
hello
this one's not a very good fan oh i
pressed it off
two funny moments with mika fight 592.
[Applause]
[Laughter]
guys remember to subscribe if you
haven't done it already
or otherwise i will find you
okay
okay
okay cover
[Laughter]
your looks like a mouse
okay i think we did okay i think pretty
good
how can you lose with that team bandana
yoda i've been expecting you much to
learn you still have young padavan
trickshot ideas not the tricks at ideas
but the video idea
and until next time until next time